And now to you, Scoutmaster.
So, uh, I was down to camp the other day, went in the trading post. the aquatic director was there
I got. I'm a little worried about him. He was trying to cash a buddy check.
Think about it, It'll come to you. Hang on, There it is,
Hey. this is podcast number 71..
Hey,
Hey.
Well, welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast. This is Clark Green.
Let's check in and see who got in touch this week.
Mike Duff wrote in and said:
I discovered your podcast last summer
And, as a new Scoutmaster, it's been a tremendous resource.
There have been many aha moments listening to your podcast.
Yeah, I'm like there's a couple of aha moments every now and again,
but there's some real ooh moments too.
Thank you for all the time it must take to put it together
And please know that it's been making a big impact on the Scouts and families
of Troop 381 in Prairie Village, Kansas.
Well, thanks very much, Mike, for your kind words.
Hello Troop 381.. Hello, Prairie Village Kansas.
Good to hear from you all.
Alan Green wrote in and said this:
I had three sons in two troops.
They're all grown up now.
I have to admit that with my first son
I probably stepped in more than I should have.
I was an assistant Scoutmaster, one among several,
and the Scoutmaster finally had a pal well
with all of us dads who were involved
and said that we got a little too emotional
when it came to our own sons.
He suggested, just like you did,
that it might be a good idea
if we worked with somebody else's son
and let our sons, you know, kind of do scouting.
I adopted the advice
and the second son was left more to himself than the first.
The third son joined another troop and I followed.
I think the best time for my sons was
when I was watching from a distance.
On two occasions
I didn't make summer camp with the troop
and my boys struggled a bit
but they overcame it without me
and I think they were the better for it.
I see parents now make the same mistakes I did.
They hover over their boy
and they don't realize that scouting
is a time for a boy to be away from home
and discover the world and society
apart from his family.
I would like to tell them
to work a little bit
and let scouting, the scout master
and the troop leaders do their work
Well. I think that's great advice, Alan,
and I really appreciate you being in touch,
Let them live their own lives a little bit.
It's really difficult
when you're a parent and a scout leader
at the same time.
It's hard to find the right perspective,
the right amount of involvement.
You know it's a puzzle for all of us,
but there's Alan encouraging everybody
that maybe a little bit less
is more for most of the scouts.
Andre Crawford wrote in on Facebook.
You can find us on Facebook
at Scout Master Blog.
Go on Facebook, search for Scout Master Blog
and hey, there we are.
And Andre joined us there
and said I was finally able
to listen to the podcast last night.
Thank you so much for taking the time
to discuss these questions.
I feel it can only be a benefit
to those of us who are new to this.
Well, thank you, Andre.
I hope to have you aboard.
Andre's asked a couple of questions
about being a scout parent
and working along with his son.
I think we were able to help out
a little bit there, Andre.
A lot of folks online left some comments
and some encouragement
Speaking about online
over at the Scout Master Blog,
this week we have a caption contest.
You can find the Scout Master Blog
by going to scoutmastercgcom
And take a look at the caption contest.
It was pretty popular this week.
A lot of people signed on to look at it
and offer a caption
for a kind of humorous photo
that one of the readers sent in,
And I would love to have you come
and take a look at it
and vote for your favorite caption.
If the photos keep coming,
maybe we can make it a weekly occurrence.
So go on to scoutmastercgcom
and take a look
And there's a wonderful,
impressive coveted prize
for the winning caption.
It's a May giveaway for the May
Scout Master newsletter,
And that prize,
which is a right in the rain
outdoor journal kit,
goes to Phil Peck,
Scout Master of Troop 141
and Kokolala, Indiana.
So, Phil, congratulations.
Thanks for answering the question
that qualified you
to be randomly selected
from all of those who gave
the right answer for that month's giveaway.
Finally, here let's see,
and Chris said this:
Clark thanks for the story
of a scout dad.
I was listening to your podcast yesterday
and I thought it was great.
I'm the father of two scouts:
One's an Eagle Scout
and one's a new Tenderfoot.
At a troop court of honor last night,
one of my sons received his Silver Palm
and one of them received his Tenderfoot rank.
I reflected on how short a time
all of this is
and how blessed I am to be a part of it.
Thank you for your wonderful podcast.
I select an adult volunteer each year.
They think makes the most difference
in their lives.
At the conclusion of the court of honor,
the Scout Master announced
that the scouts had selected me.
I don't think I've ever felt so humbled
as I did last night to receive that honor.
Wow, that's great news, Chris,
And that's a really nice tradition
for the scouts to do that annually.
And congratulations,
It sounds like you're having a wonderful time
and scouting with your boys.
Just so happy to hear it.
As it is Memorial Day weekend,
I'm going to go ahead
and re-broadcast a couple of favorites
from the archives.
One of them is talking about
volunteering with some boundaries,
and that'll be in Scout Mastership
in seven minutes or less.
And then I've got a story to tell you
from Scout Camp
about the night the helicopter landed in camp.
Yeah, one of my favorite stories
to tell from camp.
So that sounds like enough for this podcast.
So let's get started, shall we
Scout Mastership in seven minutes
or less.
Have you ever heard somebody call
being described as being generous to a fault?
I guess,
ultimately,
you could give away everything that you own,
But then you wouldn't really have the resources
to perpetuate being generous, would you?
So generosity
is a little bit of a paradoxical value.
We can't continue being generous
unless we have
maintained some store
of resources
to share.
Volunteering-
and I guess we're, you know,
absolutely talking in the specific
area of scouting,
But volunteering-
is a form of generosity
that, if you push it too far,
is going to bankrupt the virtue
that creates it.
Scouting
and church and school
and charities and any other form of volunteer
where it can demand
ever greater commitments of time
and resources until the poor volunteer
just reaches a breaking point.
you can call it burnout
or fatigue or what have you.
This happens when the volunteer reaches
that point of frustration
that just you know
they can't stand it anymore.
You've seen it happen.
If you've been around scouting long enough,
you've probably seen it happen.
Maybe it's getting ready to happen to you.
So being able to continue on as a volunteer,
as a scouter,
means you really have to have some boundaries,
And if we don't set boundaries,
there's a good chance we won't be volunteering
for very long.
We have responsibilities
of family and career
and the work that we do volunteering,
and we have to continuously
measure and prioritize these things
and they can go way off balance.
Here's some thoughts
that can lead
a volunteer to go way off balance
and, to you know,
not have a proper set of boundaries.
The first thought would be:
if I don't do it,
nobody else will.
Well,
I got to tell you honestly,
more than likely:
if you think
that you won't, you don't do it,
nobody else will.
it's more or less. you're saying:
if I don't do it, nobody else
will do it the way I think it should be done.
Am I right?
I mean, there are tasks
and positions of extraordinary importance,
but they're fewer and farther
between than we think.
If nobody else will take on
a given position or a task,
it might be because it's really
not as important as we once thought,
or
that position has been
grossly overinflated
by a previous volunteer
who kind of ignored their own boundaries.
Another thought
experience
is: nobody really knows how to do this
like I do.
Yeah, that might be true.
so train somebody else how to do it
now. truthfully, nobody's going to do it
just like you do,
but things will change
and change is not always bad.
you heard it here first.
change is not always bad.
how about this?
how about this thought?
how about this myself,
rather than to show somebody else how it's done?
how many times have you thought that
it could be true?
but volunteering is not always about efficiency.
scouting is not always about efficiency.
sometimes it's about
opening up opportunities
to let other people enjoy
the accomplishment
of volunteering.
how about this thought?
nobody really knows how to do this
like I do.
they're not going to do it,
and they're not going to do it exactly like you do,
and that's fine,
because they need to have the freedom
and the latitude that you've had
in developing your particular style
of working on something,
don't they?
isn't that the way we remain satisfied?
in this kind of work?
things are going to change,
and change isn't always bad.
staying viable
and being a contributing member
of the volunteer team is preferable
to like flaming out
in a short blaze of glory.
things begin to spin out of control
if we ignore
these factors,
and the first factor
is that emotional investments
and what you're doing as a volunteer
can skew your judgment.
here's a really good example:
a parent who volunteers to help with an organization
that serves their child
can't ever really stop being a parent.
they can try,
but it's almost impossible.
it's hard to be an unbiased volunteer
when your child's involved.
long time volunteers
who've put a lot of blood, sweat
and tears into something
tend to be overly defensive
in their work.
that's another kind of emotional investment.
this is my deal
and I don't want anybody else
screwing it up.
these two common emotional issues
can be huge blind spots
to progress,
to unemotionally evaluate situations
in our volunteer lives.
sometimes
we just can't leave
delegated responsibilities alone.
do you know what I'm talking about?
you give somebody a job
and then you want to micromanage it
because you want it done just so
well.
we have to allow other people
some autonomy in their work,
good management and leadership principles,
but the incentives are different
than the work we do for pay
and some people don't respond
to the incentives of volunteering
with the same energy and integrity
as they do when a check is involved.
people will break commitments
or make minimal efforts
that they wouldn't consider appropriate
in their professional life,
and we really can't change that.
we can only factor it into the equation
like ways
that some people are not really great volunteers
as an excuse not to delegate.
you got to delegate things off
and let people do what they're going to do.
we need to focus on the goal
and all of our immediate goals
need to serve the ultimate goal:
maintaining a vision.
what we're trying to accomplish
is as important as the work itself.
if we'll save a lot of wasted effort
and heartache
if we concentrate on the goals of our work.
we're tied up in the methods
and trying to figure that out.
let's just keep an eye on the goal.
and if it's scouting,
the goal is the success of your scouts.
we have to know our limits.
I don't know my limits.
you don't know your limits.
few people
really see themselves that clearly.
now, who knows your limits?
well, your spouse knows your limits
and you've got a few good friends
that know your limits
and we need to ask them:
are you doing too much?
do you think that I'm overextended?
and then we need to listen to the reply.
sometimes the easiest way
to fix your life as a volunteer
is a little two letter word
and oh no,
sometimes it's the right answer.
we
are fortunate to have
these wonderful people
who dedicate their time to scouting
and they have a sense of responsibility.
but sometimes that sense of responsibility,
it's easy to drive
them to greater responsibilities
with a little bit of guilt.
you know we're really having a problem with this.
nobody else will do it.
I mean, we're nice people
but we can't allow ourselves
to be compelled by a sense of duty
or guilt alone.
we have to have a sense of proportion
and responsibility
for our own lives
and sometimes that sense.
volunteering is a tremendously gratifying
and enriching experience
and we can't allow
ourselves to be pushed beyond reasonable boundaries
if we're to stay volunteers
and we're to be effective
in the work that we did.
this has to be the truth, folks,
because there is no
way
anyone could make this up.
some of the best times I ever spent
in scouting was
the years that I worked
as a staff member
at our summer camp.
it was just a wonderful time
and we got to see some things
that you know a general person
going down and camping
and kind of hanging out
would not be able to see.
some of these were good,
some of these were bad,
but one night stands out
as being a really remarkable
person
at our camp.
so around about,
I guess around about ten o'clock,
tap sounds and the campers
are all off to their campsites
and off to bed
and one of my friends
and I decided we were going to head
into town
and so we took the old camp road
out and you know, the camp road
is about a mile long or so.
it's, you know, dirt and gravel
and that's kind of unusual
at this time of night
for somebody to be headed into camp
and they're kind of swerving around
and things like that.
and we see this car approaching,
so we kind of stop
and we signal them to stop
and there's a couple of fellas
in the car who we don't know
and we ask them if they're
camped there this week
and they say no, we're kind of lost.
and we say, well, you know,
you're headed into a scout camp
and it appeared to us
as though these guys had
had a few too many
and we're very confused
about where they were headed.
so they said, yeah, well, you know,
we'll turn around, I guess
we'll head on out.
and they were kind of arguing
with each other.
but I got back in our car
and we proceeded to
head out the road,
imagining these guys would turn around
and head out with us,
and nope,
they just kept on going down into camp
when we saw that,
and so we turned around
and we followed them into camp
and we stopped them
and oh, one thing led to another
and you know it turned out to be
a couple of guys who had a bit
too much to drink
and we called the police
to go and
wait at the gate
for the police to show up.
so we were waiting there
for 10 or 15 minutes
and we see some emergency lights
up on the main road
and we say, well, they're the police,
they're coming in.
and so we're sitting at the gate
and I stepped out into the road
and kind of waved to indicate
that we were there,
we were going to lead them into camp.
comes through
screaming
through the gate of the camp,
right past us,
beeping the horns, sirens and everything,
and starts screaming down into camp
a fire truck.
so I looked at my buddy
and he looked at me
and we said we better get back down into camp,
something's wrong.
so we got in the car
and we went down
following this fire truck.
and we get a certain way down the road
and all of a sudden
there is this amazing
bright light
shining down from the sky
into a grove of trees
beside the road
and we were really freaked out
because it looked
like an alien invasion.
I'm not kidding,
I mean it was this tremendously
bright spotlight
and we hit the gas.
he said: oh my gosh,
what in the world is happening.
and we started heading back down the road
into camp.
and we got into camp
and we found out
that what had happened
is there had been a staff swim
at the pool after taps
and one of the fellas
had injured himself
and they got so upset about the injury
they decided they would call in
the Medevac unit.
and this is what the bright light was.
it was this helicopter
with- I guess they call it- a midnight sun
and it's properly named.
it's this giant search light
on the helicopter.
of course they had no idea what the pool was,
so they were kind of sweeping through camp
and of course they hit a lot of campsites.
and the story was-
I heard from several scout masters
the next day-
they were kind of sweeping through camp
and all the scouts got up
and cheered and waved to the helicopter.
the reason
the fire truck was there
is because apparently every time
they call out a Medevac,
they call out a fire truck in case
the helicopter crashes,
which is very reassuring, isn't it.
but the Medevac
finally set down
and they got the guy
and they took him out.
fortunately the injury wasn't as serious
as anybody thought
and he was back in camp within 24 hours.
but, wow,
I'll tell you what a night.
if you ever get a chance
to serve on camp staff,
you know. take the advantage of it
because it's a lot of fun.
so stay up late
and keep your eyes open-
music.
thanks for listening.
once again,
here's how to keep in touch.
read the scoutmaster blog
at scoutmastercgcom
and, while you're there,
you can subscribe
to the scoutmaster newsletter.
that's a monthly digest
of the blog and the podcast
with some great scouting resources
around a theme.
every newsletter also includes
a giveaway from one of our
affiliate sponsors.
you can subscribe
to the scoutmaster podcast
on iTunes
and, when you do,
feel free to leave a comment
or review or a rating.
you can even call in
and leave a voicemail
comment or question
that could be featured
on an upcoming podcast.
all you need to do
is dial
4-734-002.
you can follow us
at the scoutmaster blog
on Facebook
and scoutmastercg
on Twitter,
and you can email me,
Clark Green,
with your comments and questions
at scoutmastercg
at Verizonnet-
scoutmastercgatverizonnet.
I do need to remind you
that the scoutmaster blog
and the scoutmaster podcast
are not official publications
of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed
or sponsored by the Boy Scouts
of America.
Hey, it's just me
talking into a microphone,
trying to lend a hand
to scout leaders
and perhaps have a bit
of fun along the way.
It is Memorial Day weekend
and every Monday
I'm going to be
going to the
Boy Scouts of America
and I'm going to be
going to the
Boy Scouts of America
and I'm going to be
going to the
Boy Scouts of America.
and every Memorial Day.
three people loom
very large in my mind
as we remember
those who served
Once: my dad
Dad's 86 this year
and served in the
Second World War
as an infantryman
and has some
amazing stories
to tell about that.
And then
his two brothers
both passed on.
the uncle for whom
I'm named, Clark Green,
who was a seabee
and joined the service
shortly after the war
started
and was in his 30s
when he joined,
but he went on
and was in the construction
battalion of the Navy
and was part of
the Normandy invasion.
and last but certainly
not least,
my uncle, Malcolm.
my uncle Malcolm,
who served
during the Battle of the
Bulge,
was injured
pretty severely.
I think of
all those who served,
who are serving now,
and how much
their sacrifice,
the time that they spend
defending
our country,
makes possible
little things
like this podcast,
like our scout troops,
like our homes,
our churches,
our communities,
and I'm so very thankful
that they've been there.
What wouldn't be
a proper scout master
podcast without
hearing from our founder,
Sir Robert Baden Powell?
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you
and good camping.
My thank you, sir.
Until next time.